make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so it occurred to me recently and I
actually asked us on Twitter it occurred
to me recently that I feel like we
covered the first issue of Legion of
Doom because it only involved what was
going on with the totality storyline at
the time and then we and then we didn't
cover anymore and anyway it was
interesting to me because the Legion of
the way Legion of Doom is done it's
they're more like interlude right like
you have like the main you have a story
arc and it kind of shuffles back and
forth so Scott Snyder will be like hey
here's what the Justice League is doing
and then it's like here's what Lex
Luthor and the Legion are doing and then
here's what the Justice League are doing
and here's what the Legion are doing but
it's kind of cool because technically
speaking the Legion of Doom arc is an
ongoing art which is to say it's
multiple parts but each part is written
almost of its self-contained way at
least it is right now in the beginning
because right now it's more of like a
recruitment drive right like it's Lex
Luthor going around and trying to
recruit people and in this one it's
basically the Joker now the Joker's got
a long standing history and a Legion of
super-heroes right because for the most
part the Legion was by and large
designed to be to kind of like the
antithesis to the Justice League almost
like an injustice league of its own in
the sense that like each one was
basically a main villain of a Justice
League member and now the rosters waxed
and waned over the years it is it has
changed I mean it hasn't stayed
consistent constantly but for the most
part like the core characters have kind
of been there and the Joker's played
some pretty cool roles in the Legion of
super-heroes for example like when
Alexander Luthor from from from an
alternate reality and Infinite Crisis
storyline showed up and then wouldn't
let Joker become part of like his group
The Joker killed him at the end of
Infinite Crisis so it's kind of a cool
little thing the Joker's played that
role multiple times but what this does
is it basically picks up with like this
scheme Joker has right of like a giant
balloon with Joker toxin and so on and
so forth it's this kind of Joker being
Joker is really what it is Scott Snyder
you know I'm sorry not Scott Snyder
James Tinian rather he's the one that's
writing this but he's like meanwhile and
in like the Legion of Doom Joker's
creating a giant balloon with toxin
inside which is kind of cool but what
happens is once the Joker goes back into
like his office so to speak which is
kind of weird to see the Joker having
like an office I always assume he just
kind of operated out of like a big
warehouse or something like that with no
real like office office right like I
imagine him sitting here like conducting
business you know and like talking to
his manager I told you Percy get me that
deal you know or something like that but
uh he of course he finds Lex Luthor in
there now the exchange between Lex
Luthor and the Joker is kind of cool
because when it comes to these
characters for the for the new comic
book
reader and even for me to a degree
looking at looking at DC kind of like
you know a relative new guy being that
I've only been reading it for you know a
little over half a decade when you when
you look at this and you look at the
Joker and Lex Luthor of course it makes
sense they existed like this same
universe right like Batman Superman
Joker and Lex Luthor but when you look
at when you look at them for what they
are
you almost narrowly see them crossover
outside of the Legion of Doom and so
when you when you see this kind of
exchange take place it's like this is
kind of cool right like the Joker knows
exactly who Lex Luthor is and Lex Luthor
knows exactly who the Joker is but the
funny thing about this and this is
what's so interesting is Lex Luthor's
intelligence kind of gets the better of
them in a you know here in a little bit
and that's one of the big differences
right like I still argue to this point
Lex Luthor is probably the smartest
person in the DC Universe I mean while
Batman is super intelligent Batman's
intelligence almost never gets the
better of him he uses it as more of a
tool as opposed to a means to stand on
top of the shoulders of others and say I
am better than you
and so that's because that's what Lex
Luthor does it really kind of begins to
sort of take hold but it's interesting
because the Joker knows that Lex Luthor
has had dealings with the Batman who
last now this takes place before the
Batman who laughs miniseries right so it
takes place before all that happens this
really goes way way back and so with
that happening like it's really one of
our first little indications that like
the Joker's aware of the Batman who
laughs now of course we have like a lot
of things that we're going on with
regards to like Batman and signal levels
little story lines and so on and so
forth but outside of Joker's dealings
you know and during the events of like
Dark Knight's metal it's really one of
the first things after that that is kind
of like yeah I'm well aware the Batman
who laughs is back like I'm well aware
of the fact that he's here I know what
he's about I know who he is I know how
dangerous he can be and that's what he
tells Lex Luthor you have no idea what
you're getting into dealing with the
Batman who lasts you have no clue what
kind of schemes and what kind of things
he has in store for you if you if he
ends up getting loose you think you know
but you believe you know because you're
so arrogant and full of hubris you think
there's no way that you couldn't no but
like you have no idea what's there and
so he basically says like there's no way
I'm going to operate inside of your of
your Legion of Doom with the Batman who
lasts now the implication kinda seems to
be here from Tinian that the Joker's
scared of the Batman who lasts and
there's good reason to be because a bad
man who lies has an answer to the
question what if the Joker had Batman's
intelligence what could he do what kind
of Horrors could he unleashed it makes
sense that on some level the Joker would
be afraid of him because it's kind of
like hey look I'm crazy but
not Batman smart but like what if I was
though imagine my my craziness being put
to the task my insanity is the Joker is
limited to things like trying to
copyright fish and like testing Batman
by pretending like him his face in the
face of like all the other members of
the bathroom we have been cut off like
my schemes are relatively basic flooding
the entire city of Gotham with Joker
toxin and living the city going to like
disarray but it's like I do what I do
because I just love madness and I love
craziness but Batman who laughs loves
that too but he did smartest Batman so
like good luck and that's kind of the
crazy thing is because we end up finding
out there like where where Lex Luthor
says you know he basically makes a deal
with the Joker and says you can be part
of my Legion and I'll drop the Batman
who lasts he'll be out of the picture we
of course know that he doesn't and this
basically lead to select the Joker
watches him watching this conversation
between Lex Luthor and the Batman who
last knowing he broke his promise and so
from here it kind of goes into this big
drive right like he got got mr. freeze
you've got a Solomon Grundy you've got
like all these different characters of
course you got scarecrow so on and so
forth but they're all there to see
whether or not they can be recruited in
the league alongside cheetah marilla
Grodd and alongside Sinestro as well as
Lex Luthor and the Joker and it's kind
of nuts because what would basically end
up finding out is like currently the
Legion of Doom base of operations is on
the move so like nobody's gonna find it
but is one of these things worse like
they're all gonna be tested they're all
gonna have to go through this sort of
initiation to see whether or not they
can make the cut but before they can do
all that when they get their little you
know boxes or party favors or whatever
they open them up they're all full of
Joker's Hawks and the Joker's basically
like poisoned every major supervillain
that could possibly be part of the
Legion of Doom right and it's a cool
thing to see because where Lex Luthor
says well hey I plan for something like
this you know you're the one that
basically got to have the interrogation
room you're the one that got to design
all the traps and all the deadly means
of gaining information and so on and so
forth that's your thing I was well
prepared for something like this The
Joker says oh I know oh I know you were
well prepared for something like this so
I didn't just turn the interrogation
room into my mad house into my weapon I
turn the whole facility into a weapon
and it's nuts because basically like Lex
Luthor's running and fleeing for his
life and this is cool because the way
the James Tinian does this even Lex
Luthor himself and to a degree is kind
of like I had no idea this is how crazy
the Joker could be I had no idea could
pull off things like this like I had no
idea that he could basically turn the
entire building into a giant deathtrap
and I would have no idea I didn't know
Joker was this smart
and that's one of the cool things about
this character is that Joker really kind
of comes off is just a goofy slapstick
nonsensical guy who kill you as well as
look at you that's kind of like it right
let's how most people see him yes he's
dangerous but like not very smart but
then you see something like this unfold
and it's like okay so like he was
basically able to operate under the
scenes of Lex Luthor without Lex really
knowing now the other half of this is it
kind of hits on the nose of the fact
that like Lex Luthor's intelligence is
not as enemy
it's his arrogance and hubris everyone
is below him no one is as smart as him
no one's as capable as him no one's as
good as Lex Luthor is in terms of
putting his intelligence to task and so
because that he overlooks guys like the
Joker who while they're not on the same
level as Lex are still very intelligent
and very dangerous in their own right
and it's cool to see it's really really
awesome to have unfold and so once
everything kind of winds down of course
Lex Luthor's basically you know chained
up and then you end up having like the
Joker sitting there with like all the
other members of the Legion who were
there but they have a kind of a docile
toxin that's designed to kind of keep
them at bay and and Joker literally
starts running over all this saying like
hey like nobody ever believes that
Joker's this intelligent nobody ever
believes the Joker's as capable the only
one who knows how really dangerous I am
is Batman but I spent the last few
months basically reconstructing the
entire base designing all these death
traps creating all these terrible things
this little flower that I have on my
chest I could squirt this toxin at the
right angle into your temples and it'll
just start burning away at your
intelligence and little by little your
brain will start to erode and the only
one who will really be able to pick up
on it will be Superman because it'll
take so long and because it'll it'll
impact you in such a small degree your
brains not gonna erode away over the
course of three days Batman can figure
that out only Superman would really know
what's going on but it would start start
homing in and taking out small sections
of your brain and you would notice your
intelligence decreasing all the while
you would be totally aware I'll take
away the one thing you prize the most
the one thing you value more than
anything I will reduce you down to
nothing more than just a guy who's
fumbling and bumbling in the world
trying to just barely understand what in
the heck is going on after doing all
that understand Lex that's nothing
compared to what the Batman who laughs
will do to you that's what's so cool
about this is the Joker understands how
dangerous the Batman who last is right
he's like you know you have your Legion
of Doom and you want to have all these
grand schemes and you want to pretend to
be God and all that kind of stuff but
none of it will
matter the Batman who lasts will take
everything you know and love twist it
inside out and destroy it in front of
your eyes and you will be helpless to do
anything about it
you have no earthly clue what he will do
to you know no concept no bearing of
what he will do to you you're smart sure
but like he's Batman smart so imagine
Batman with my insanity working together
making your life a living hell there's
nothing you could do to stop him it's
amazing because what it does is it
really kind of puts a perspective I mean
a lot of the recent events with the
Batman who last mini-series has done
that but even before that this put into
perspective just how dangerous that guy
is and even on some degree how fearful
Joker is of the Batman who lasts because
in reality the Joker would have to be
foolish to have no measure of fear oven
and while the Joker is goofy and silly
and very very dangerous and does some
crazy things he's no fool he's just as
out to preserve his own life as anybody
else if for no other reason they
constantly go round and round with the
bat but it's one of these really awesome
things because in the midst of all this
because of everything that goes on all
the possible recruits leave they all
basically bail out and so that all
that's left is again kind of right back
where they started with regards to
Sinestro and like Gorilla Grodd and
cheetah as well as Lex Luthor The Joker
bails out the Joker leaves and again
it's a smart move because Joker's like
you're literally setting yourself up to
fail like you're putting yourself in a
position to where you're gonna lose
everything you know and love and that's
gonna be the end of you that will be the
story of Lex Luthor the man who is
foolish enough to believe he could get
one up on the Batman who lasts and so
what Lex ends up doing it's kind of
pulling up this a scar I'll point out
this this trump card and certainly
saying fine if this is how things are
and if what we need is a person who's as
intelligent as Batman if not smarter
then we have to kind of pull some
strings and so what we end up finding
out is that on the backburner what Lex
Luthor's been doing is working on
recreating and bringing back Brainiac
that he needs a brains behind the
operation really kind of sitting down
taking Joker's words to heart not really
going as far as to say like fine I'll
give up my quest with about with the
Batman who lasts but simply saying like
if we're gonna be dealing with a guy
like him we need a guy smarter than him
we need a 12th level intellect we need
Brainiac with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come let's explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]
you